und was heißt all das für die Welt
fragen wir Christian Mölling
Politikwissenschaftler Fachgebiet
Sicherheit und Verteidigung bei der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik guten Abend Herr Mölling hallo
guten Abend Herr sers ist die Ukraine
dabei diesen Krieg zu
verlieren wir haben ja von vorne rein
gesagt dass alles das was in der Ukraine
passiert Gewinnen oder Verlieren ganz
stark davon abhängt was der Westen
liefert oder auch nicht liefert also es
ist auch unsere sozusagen unsere
Verantwortung die die wir dort sehen wie
weit wir sie wahrnehmen oder nicht
wahrnehmen aber man kann zurzeit sagen
ja es sieht zurzeit nicht gut aus
Russland spielt auf Zeit und die Ukraine
bekommt nicht das was jetzt zugesagt
worden ist von daher ist es zur Zeit so
dass man sich schon fragen muss wie
sehen wir auf das nächste halbe Jahr
denn ganz klar ist nach diesem Winter
möchte die Ukraine gerne die nächste
Offensive starten rüstet der Westen die
Ukraine in diese Richtung aus es ist ja
vielleicht nicht nur der nächste Winter
der Oberbefehlshaber der ukrainischen
Armee spricht von einer patsituation und
einem Zitat zermürbenden Grabenkrieg der
sich über Jahre hinziehen könnte hat der
Westen dafür die
Geduld möglicherweise hat er das nicht
der ukrainische oberkommandier hat aber
auch gesagt was man tun kann um da
rauszukommen ich glaube wenn man sagt
wir haben die Geduld dafür nicht
gleichzeitig ist aber unsere Sicherheit
mit der der Ukraine verbunden dann sind
wir offensichtlich aber zurzeit nicht
bereit in der Lage die Konsequenzen
daraus zuziehen also wir gucken nicht
nur auf die Ukraine wir gucken auch wie
das Kaninchen vor der Schlange auf das
was in Washington passiert wir sehen
eigentlich all die wesentlichen
Ereignisse die dazu führen dass nicht
nur die Situation der Ukraine sondern
auch unsere eigene schlechter wird aber
die Konsequenz im Handeln die fehlt zur
Zeit sie haben gerade Washington
angesprochen also die Frage wie viele
Hilfe aus Washington aus den USA
weiterhin Richtung Ukraine kommt und
dann auch die Frage ob möglicherweise
Donald Trump zurückkehrt ins Weiße Haus
warum kümmert oder warum scheint das
Europa im Moment so wenig zu kümmern als
dass wir uns schon konkret darauf
vorbereiten würden ja ich glaube es es
kümmert uns als als ein Ereignis
von dem alle wissen dass es kommt weil
es so sicher ist aber wir nutzen die
Phase davor nicht man könnte beiden
jetzt ja quasi unterstützen auch dadurch
dass man eben die Ukraine nicht zu einem
solchen Wahlkampfthema machen
nicht dass es dazu kommt dass es so ein
wahlkampftha wird indem die Europäer
mehr mehr Verantwortung und damit
einfach mehr Last übernehmen für diesen
Konflikt und die Ukraine und
unterstützen aber da zögern wir
tatsächlich zumindest ein Teil der
Europäer ein wichtiger Teil der Europäer
ist sich zurzeit nicht im Klaren was es
eigentlich machen will um die Ukraine
weiter zu unterstützen wenn die
Amerikaner Wegbrechen der Bundeskanzler
hat schon vor längerer Zeit gesagt mit
der Waffe an der Schläfe lässt sich
nicht verhandeln das sieht man aber
offenbar ja nicht mehr überall so wird
am Ende Kiev an den Verhandlungstisch
gedrängt
ähm selbst wenn Kiev an den
Verhandlungstisch gedrängt wird ist das
eben nicht das Ende
diese Idee glaube ich macht sich zurzeit
so hier und da in einer Ecke in in
Berlin breit dass man eigentlich hofft
man mussste noch ein paar Monate
aushalten dann wäre es vorbei und dann
wäre es so wie früher aber ich glaube
das ist der Trugschluss es wird nicht
mehr so wie früher werden die Ukraine
wird auch nicht bereit sein eine
Millionen ihrer Menschen und zehtausende
von Kindern in russischer Gewalt
zurückzulassen und die Frage ist ob das
was Europa versprochen hat entweder dass
Russland nicht gewinnen darf oder aber d
so dass sogar die Ukraine gewinnt ob all
diese Versprechungen und auch die
Sicherheitsgarantien die angesprochen
worden sind ob die irgendwas wert sind
wir entscheiden hier glaube ich gerade
in erheblichen Maße darüber wie
vertrauenswürdig wir eigentlich als
Europa noch sind aber wenn es wie sie
sagen nicht mehr so wird wie früher und
wenn es auch so wie es aktuell läuft ja
letztlich nicht lange weitergehen kann
was bleibt denn dann noch
na wir haben noch handlungskapazitäten
also
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass alles das
was heute passiert oder auch nicht
passiert den Krieg in in sech Monaten
beeinflusst dann gibt es quasi eine neue
Liste von all den Dingen die die Ukraine
braucht um im nächsten Jahr eben nicht
in einen Stellungskrieg zu rutschen oder
dort wenn sie dort jetzt schon ist den
weiterzuführen sondern tatsächlich die
Fähigkeit zu haben daraus auszubrechen
und weitere Erfolge zu machen die Frage
ist ob die Europäer sagen ja okay wir
sind bereit da rein zu investieren wir
gehen auch ins Risiko bisl sieht es
nicht so aus als ob wir bereit sind das
Risiko
einzugehen ich würde gerne noch zum
Schluss ganz kurz auf das ganz große
Bild ck ich habe heute einen Satz eines
Historikers gelesen der mir nicht mehr
aus dem Kopf geht Kriege wie diese sagt
er und der meint D mit den Ukraine Krieg
haben Konsequenzen die Jahrzehnte
andauern wer diesen Krieg verliert oder
gewinnt das wird uns alle auf 10 20 und
vielleicht noch viel mehr Jahre prägen
ist das allen bewusst
ähm ich habe den Eindruck dass es nicht
allen bewusst ist vor allen Dingen nicht
denjenen die die Entscheidung treffen
viel wichtiger ist aber dass man das
nicht in Jahrzehnten messen muss sondern
dass man relativ klar sagen muss muss
dass uns die äh die Konsequenzen wenn
wir der Ukraine nicht helfen und damit
unsere eigene Sicherheit weiterhin
gefährden dass uns diese Konsequenzen
wahrscheinlich schon in fünf oder sech
Jahren ins Haus stehen werden weil
Russland sich auf der einen Seite
ermutigt fühlt dass man Erfolg haben
kann mit Krieg um seine Interessen
durchzusetzen und gleichzeitig quasi die
die Ernte einfahren wird aus seiner
angelaufenen Kriegswirtschaft und damit
im Grundung in der Lage sein wird Europa
weiterhin zu bedrohen und dann geht es
nicht um die Frage ob es einen
Nuklearschlag oder nukleare Eskalation
gegen Kiev geht sondern um eine nukleare
Eskalation die möglicherweise dann
Berlin ins Zentrum rückt Christian
Mölling vielen Dank für ihre Expertise
heute abend ich danke ihnen schönen
Abend